So now coming back to this picture here,
you see what I meant when I said that hardness of a problem
can be measured as both a function of
the size of the imput and the structure of the imput,
so in the case of the vertex covered, it turns out that
what makes solving vertex cover hard
is actually the size of the vertex cover itself.
So if there's a small vertex cover, then the problem is easy
and if it's large, then the problem becomes hard.
Now of course, this immediately raises a question for
the book of the laws of NP-completeness
and that question is, is every problem fixed-parameter tractable?
That depends, it depends on what you consider as a parameter,
and one parameter I will soon introduce to you as well
is a parameter called distance from triviality,
but unfortunately in general, not every NP-complete problem
seems to be fixed-parameter tractable.
So for vertex cover, we have just shown
that if you use the size of the solution as a parameter,
then yes, this problem is fix-parameter tractable
using K, and by K I mean the size of the solution of course.
Now what about clique and independent set?
And again, we can consider these 2
problems together because they're so similar.
And here unfortunately, I have a bit of bad news for you
because using K, by which I mean the size of the solution,
that's highly unlikely to be fixed-parameter tractable.
So by highly unlikely, what I mean is it would not
be something as similar as P=NP or something like that,
but still there is evidence in a way that is similar to P versus NP
that clique and independent set are not fixed-parameter tractable
at least if you consider the parameter to be the size of an optimal solution.
Now what about shortest tour?
Well, one possible parameter here would be using D,
the size of a shortest tour,
and here again, it seems somewhat unlikely
that the problem is fixed-parameter tractable,
but for shortest tour, another parameter has been investigated
that actually seems rather promising,
and that parameter is called using distance from triviality,
and there it turns out shortest tour actually could be fixed-parameter tractable.
Now what is distance from triviality?